male body dysmorphia is on track to
overtake female body dysmorphia within
the next few decades does that surprise
you no I think it's always been a thing
but especially now with how big social
media is and how jacked so many people
are uh I think of course it's a it's a
big problem but do you know there's a
guy who's really good at calling people
out for editing their photos have you
seen that guy I don't know his name but
he's got quite a big social media
following and basically anybody who has
photos shops their photo or videos M he
gets them oh wow so he's doing a good
job
he's making sure that people are being
truthful with the things that they're
posting but that makes you think how
many people are editing even people who
are literally jacked and shredded they
are still editing their photos further
to bring in their waist bring out the
lats and just it's crazy so especially
with women as well imagine how bad that
is for the average person who's
comparing M themselves to all these
people and a lot of those people are
actually still editing their photos to
look moreable peaked they've just
trained they've got a pump they're in
good lighting they've got a good
photographer a good camera good lens
they've got a tan blah blah blah and
then on top of that they're editing
their photos as well yeah it it's you
know I think that that's it's one thing
that messed me up a little bit when I
competed so I competed twice and
obviously when you compete that really
is the best that you are going to look
probably in your life especially for me
in terms of how low I got my body fat
percentage so when I would look in the
mirror particularly after the show when
it was like more
memorable I would be like pretty fat
because you had yourself because I was
comparing myself to the sub 10% body fat
person that I was looking in the mirror
which is like that says it all that not
only can you have other people out there
in the world for guys and girls that
make them feel uncomfortable about their
body or they're taller or more jacked or
more whatever but you can also be that
for you too you know this is I wanted to
talk about this like you know you're 34
33 33 I'm 35 and we're getting to the
stage where we're like right okay you
know recovery from workouts takes a
little bit longer recovery from nights
out takes an awful lot longer a couple
more wrinkles on the forehead my
photographer keeps reminding me of that
cheers Rob don't listen to don't listen
to them uh yeah just thinking about as
that happens you almost use yourself as
well I used to be X or Y as I used to be
this able to get up and and train hard
or lift this much or be this lean or eat
this many calories or whatever and then
you can't so you use yourself as your
own barometer and you know the
discomfort that's associated with that
of not being as jacked as you used to be
not being as able to recover from work
as you used to be it's like a harsh
realization like the the body smoria I
think with me in particular I've I've
not really been that person that's
always compared myself to others but
more so I'm always comparing myself to
myself and how good I have looked in the
past that's what I'm always comparing
myself to and you're right I think
fortunately for me now I still feel like
I'm I I don't know if I have peaked I
think especially if I was to fine-tune a
few things M the peak is still yet to
come but when I do have these thoughts
of okay well Sony downhill from here
yeah that I'm like you do know that I I
think about that and this whatever you
want to call about it like aging
gracefully as a man whatever that means
right uh probably not taking all of your
selfworth from the way you look might be
a good place to
start and I think oh you know how
difficult it's going to be recovery from
the workouts and not being as Jack not
being the fastest guy in the room or the
strongest guy in the room or whatever
but then you realize that that's like
women from age 25 yeah I think we we as
men have got it good like we can we can
get older and age and get the the the
gray whiskers more wrinkles and if
anything it's still kind of it might
even make you look better like I
remember I looked back at some footage
from when I
was even like 20 27 28 and I feel
personally I look a lot better now like
I had like maybe it didn't help that I
was like clean shaving myself all the
time but I looked you grow into with
your style a little bit but yeah you
know for for all that I can be
chronically fearful of my own mortality
and getting older and all the rest of it
thinking yeah but the speed of descent
isn't as rapid as it is for yeah women
so yeah the male body dismorphia thing
being on track to overtake female body
dysmorphia kind of doesn't surprise me I
think you you probably have to be
careful with who you're following and
who you're comparing yourself to like if
if you were an average guy and you are
following the like top 1% of athletes in
the world the top
0.01% of course you're going to feel
pretty small in comparison to them so it
depends like for someone like me if I am
following like the elite you trained
with Kai green this morning yeah so but
in town at the moment so if I if I'm
following them I'm the type of person
that gets inspired by it like I get
motivated by that but other people can
take it the opposite way and be like oh
that's unachievable I'll never get there
and I feel worthless yeah what's your
relationship like with social media
now
oh I
think I would love to not have to be on
it so much but I know it's something
which I need to be doing regularly more
than ever like you especially with what
we do in today's day and age you have to
be
everywhere um even to this day I don't
like how I still get sucked into it
every single time in terms of the the
Doom scrolling I go on there to do a
task then I get distracted by something
and then I'm scrolling then I still
haven't done the like oh 15 minutes
[__] hell hang on I didn't do the
thing I supposed it so you have to go
back onto it again so I think um yeah
from that point of view I hate how good
it is at just sucking you in and
rewarding you for just getting like a
notification or whatever
um in terms of like YouTube and stuff
I'm I'm I'm quite selective with what I
consume like I when I go on to YouTube I
like to watch things which I'm going to
No Doubt get educated by I like to watch
a lot of podcasts anything which I'm
going to learn something by Instagram as
well it's it's it's a bit of a mess I
have it I like now to employ as many
people as possible to just run the
platform yeah so that I don't have to go
onto it I still
still actually it's a recent thing I
don't look at comments anymore okay that
used to still mess with your head I
think particularly like with the the gym
related videos I would do a gym workout
or try and do an educational video
talking about like uh how to do this
exercise or whatever and then the
comment section is all steroids steroids
steroids steroid steroids why you lying
to us fake Natty and it's just like I'm
I'm trying to help people yet the the
whole conversation is about whether or
not I'm natural and it used to annoy me
so much that I actually pivoted away
from making gym videos because it was so
annoying that because no one's talking
about your supposed steroid use in a
lifestyle Vlog in Marb yeah so like the
the less gym related stuff in it there's
kind of less uh negativity dude I mean
that's that's something that's really
true that the audience gets to influence
the direction of the Creator in a lot of
ways and if they make them feel very
uncomfortable about whatever it is that
they're doing going to start to lean
away from that type of content was one
of the reasons why I got hair transplant
cuz when I was losing my hair and it was
thinning really badly when I look back
at it now I was like like it was pretty
bad and I was like I don't ever remember
it being that bad I was there was a
six-month phase where probably should
have just shaved it like you know how
when everyone's losing their hair they
try and just cling onto it and you just
got like little strands just you know
it's looking pretty pathetic and lonely
and the whole comment section was just
about ah he's losing his like oh the
steroid again and it was just like I'm
making these videos yet all everybody
wants to talk about is the hair loss
yeah well we spoke about this the last
time that I had you on I I mentioned
that I admire the fact that you've
chosen to stay out of Internet drama
yeah as best you can I think that's
partly both yours and my disposition
which is I'm just not very conflict
person I quite like having been chill
and and peaceful and relaxing and I'm
not in it for the beef but there's
certainly it feels extra unfair if you
haven't done made a career out of like
James Smith right my partner in neonic
he made a career calling people out for
like [__] Fitness advice or for lying
about stuff or for editing photos or for
do being you know
unethical it's kind of Open Season for
him because guess what like that the way
that you went about think I knew like as
we were in the buildup launching this
drink and he started doing call out
videos about Prime and everything else
and I was like James you do know that by
doing this you're just making it open
season on us but anyway for him it's
like all right well you know if you've
spent a lot of time criticizing other
people it's kind of Open Season on you
that's not to say that people who've
never criticized should be insulated
from any
criticism but it's just like hang on
what have I done to you why you dragging
me into this yeah in a way I was it's
kind of good in one sense because it's
exposure but when it is a person of
authority talking [__] about you then
they have a a huge audience who do
listen to every word that they say big
influence and it's kind of a it's a only
one argument is being put forward of
course you could do a response video and
give your side of it but where does it
end and then they're like yes he I've
got him I've got him yeah yeah but I
think you know even for the people that
aren't content
creators every everybody especially with
Tik Tok Tik Tok is
so the number of followers you have
basically doesn't count if you put an
insane video on Tik Tok guess what
there's a million likes on it you know
if it's really really good and you catch
the algorithm at the right time etc etc
which means now that
everybody content creator or mother that
happens to take a funny video of her dog
doing something is open to the entire
internet saying oh that's that's animal
abuse or whatever you know what I mean
like there's just everybody's open to
criticism and I think
some kind of education about how to deal
with
criticism from strangers on the internet
would probably be a pretty good thing
yeah for everybody to learn yeah uh well
I remember when I started with YouTube I
think whenever you're on a platform that
people can post anonymously they'll go
harder they'll be more Relentless with
what it is that they want to say and I
think that took me a bit of getting used
to and I almost had to learn okay I got
to develop thick skin here in order to
just carry on with doing it I mean even
the people who are like the the nicest
guys ever that you would just and girls
you just think how can you not like this
person like such a likable person
they're still getting hate for something
tons and tons of distaste yeah well
there's an idea called the bystander
effect have you heard of this no so um
you have a a crime let's say somebody's
being attacked right in the um Courtyard
of a bunch of FL Flats somewhere and
everybody that lives in the flats hears
the attack going on and there's someone
you know screaming for help or saying
please ring the police or whatever all
of the people think that one of the
other people will do the right thing and
call the police or whatever bystander
effect and there's kind of a an
anonymity equivalent here which is when
you know that you're not going to be
found out you can almost lean in and be
a little bit be way more mean no one's
going to come after you you're not going
to be held accountable for the things
you say it's a burner account on YouTube
like you know I mean so dude some of the
stuff like anti-Semitism and stuff
that's happened this year on on like
random comment threads and I'll see
people talking in code about like or
like you know whatever reverse
anti-Semitism crazy crazy crazy stuff
one of the things I was interested in
one of the reasons I asked about the
male body dysmorphia thing and and your
relationship with social media I didn't
think I've I asked you this what drove
you in the first place to dedicate so
much time to
going to the gym and building a business
and and doing stuff like that because
it's been a very very long road
significantly more consistent than most
people are and now it might be habit but
what was it originally I think
originally on the back end of when
Facebook was at its peak and then when
Instagram started I think I just liked
being able to Showcase all the hard work
that I had put in with the gym I was
like oh like this is an opportunity to
show the world like this is what I've
achieved but what about before that what
about when you started training like why
did you start
training
so I think it was probably a combination
of a few different things because I've
playing rugby for a solid nine years and
I enjoyed it but I think near the end of
last few years of playing rugby like
it's maybe I didn't like the idea of
being in a team and I I've became very
frustrated sometimes when I wanted to do
something like I wanted to switch this
game around
but I had to rely on the other 14
players to sort their [__] out that I
felt like a lot of the time I was out of
control so of I like the way that the
gym thing was a very individual thing it
was like it was just about you you in
complete control um I remember the first
time when I I I remember just walking
into this the gym at the school that I
went to this probably 17 years
old and nobody was there wasn't really a
thing there was no I had no idea what I
was doing but I I put like my favorite
music on the speakers and just started
like just using a few of the machines
and I was just super happy doing it and
then I remember looking in the mirror
and saw a little bit of a pump and I was
like [__] H like I look good so it was
the the instant reward that you would
get from going to the gym which made me
almost want more of it and then I think
I always wanted to just be a bigger guy
I remember there was one point when I
was on um I don't know if I was 15 or 16
ended up getting mugged on a bus so I
was I was on a bus where you from leads
leads yeah double decker bus and yeah
these two guys came on and basically
just started [__] with me and then
wanted to take my money and I felt
completely useless I couldn't do
anything about it I was like a little
skinny kid back then so I was shook by
the whole experience and I felt like
completely unprepared for any kind of
Confrontation um that I thought well I
need I need to put on some size like I
don't know maybe I should learn how to
fight but the easiest thing for me to do
right now is just to look like the typee
of guy that you probably wouldn't want
to get in a fight with and it's been I
think it's been pretty good the fact
that I've been able to put on size I I'm
not the type of person that people come
up to and want to start a fight with
which is good most of the time which is
good I I I never go looking for trouble
you can overshoot that there's
definitely a size that you get to where
people want like I want to [__] drop
this guy exactly you're in the you're in
this goldilock Zone in the middle yeah I
think um it's so nice to hear that to
hear and it was the same for me like I
was you know skinny kid picked on
sometimes in school for not being as as
like big as everybody else or whatever
and I didn't want to be like that I
wanted I wanted to feel like I had more
physical
formidability and um I don't I don't
know if it had something to do with me I
used to be like really awkward with
girls as well so I don't know if that
had a maybe my chat was so bad that I
thought well to compensate for this
horrendous chat that I have at least I
can look good and then I don't have to
do as much
work my social anxiety doesn't matter as
much yeah but even with that man like
all of these things are the pure
beautiful reasons why guys start going
to the gym and a good chunk of that I
think has been lost in talk about body
dysmorphia and comparison and and you
know uh unrealistic male body image
standards and stuff like that but so
much of it is just
I want to feel more like a man when I've
still got kind of the body of a boy and
I want to be more attractive to women
and I want to be more confident I I I
don't understand why all men don't want
to try and improve their physique and
the way they look because so much of
what I have achieved to this point in
time has come from my physique like it's
it's crazy how many doors that's opened
for me but at the same time just the the
confidence that it gives you I know
there's quite a lot of big jacked guys
who had you know just don't have that
confidence but if if you are unhappy
about your life or this something not
going right the easiest thing you can do
is just to at least try and sort out
your physical appearance and usually
once you sort that out good things start
coming after that the bars set pretty
low as well if you go if you do push P
leg split three times a week for a year
you're probably in the top 1% of that's
that's really all all you need I think a
lot of people they get um confused and
they think oh well if in order to look
like that or if I want to look better
then I have to go to the gym six times a
week and I have to start eating this
boring stuff every single day in reality
you don't need to do that it's it's just
the the consistent efforts every single
week but most people they go through
periods whether it be a few weeks or a
few months where everything's going good
and then it just it stops and then
people come up to me and they're like oh
yeah yeah I'm just kind of unhappy with
my shape at the moment I'm like so well
tell me about your your training what's
it been like and they say oh if so I
haven't really been to the gym for the
past six months I'm
like how have you not been to the gym
for the past six months like of course
you're not where you want to be because
you've done six months of nothing like
you should be doing something every
single week even if you have a bad week
and you train twice it's still better
than doing nothing in other news this
episode is brought to you by element
element is a tasty electrolyte drink mix
with everything that you need and
nothing that you don't it's a healthy
alternative to sugary electrolyte drinks
and it is the best way that I have
started my morning every single day for
over 3 years now it contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium with no
sugar no coloring no artificial
ingredients or any other junk your
adenosine system the caffeine Acton
isn't active for the first 90 minutes of
the day but your adrenal system is and
salt acts on your adrenal system so if
you want to be more awake want to
regulate your appetite curb cravings and
have better brain health this is the way
to start your day head to drink LM
nt.com sodern wisdom to get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box plus there is a no BS no
questions asked refund policy so you can
buy it 100% risk-free that's drink LM
nt.com
slod wisdom what's that sort of Journey
taught you about where confidence comes
from because it has to come from
something more than simply the way that
you look yeah I learned that I
think it's it's many different areas of
life I don't think I was fully I was
fully content and comfortable with the
person that I was probably at the age of
20 27 28 I just feel like at that point
in time I was like okay yeah my my [__]
is sorted now I think a lot of it came
from being financially comfortable as
well I feel like it's quite hard to be
com to be comfortable not not
comfortable Sor confident when you have
no money in your account like you you
could you could look the part you could
be you know great with women or great at
talking but let's say for example if I
was in a room full of very successful
entrepreneurs that had a lot of money I
would
feel the absolute opposite of confident
I'd be like wow I really have nothing to
offer in this situation right now so the
moment I got my finances
sorted I was happy with my physique the
way I looked the lessons which I had
learned from previous relationships and
just from previous work experiences what
about the uh social confidence or the
confidence with women as well
though I think that came from just
experience of having lots of different
relationships
because I just like now if all the past
few years when I'd been dating someone
the first time or going on first date
it's just like oh here we go again like
you just know you know what to do you
know what to say and everything is is
good but I I think as well this
being on YouTube has helped massively so
I have drastically improved my ability
to speak in front of the camera speak in
front of like lots of different people
to be able to have a conversation with
someone to be able to entertain the
audience that's watching you that has
massively helped with my social
interactions because most of the time
I'm more introverted like you look at
the introverted extroverted scale I'm
more on the introverted side I think be
before the days of YouTube I was a lot L
more introverted like I had my my group
of friends and my Social Circle but You'
never see me come out my shell unless I
was with my closest friends and even
then if I was in a situation with like a
lot of people I'd be the quiet guy not
really saying anything I would just
listen so the whole journey through the
social media the YouTube has helped me
to come out my shell and I'm a lot more
you know confident now I have a lot more
to say but there's still that
introverted aspect to me where let's say
for example you had a day full of
socializing talking whatever I come back
home and I'm like dead and I need to be
alone just to recharge so it's uh yeah I
think I always ask myself this and I
want to ask you this as well if there's
one thing that you could change about
yourself what would it be because for me
I think I would like if I could be more
extroverted I feel like I would be able
to go further with my career and
everything that I'm doing because I
would just naturally want to be meeting
everyone going to events chatting to
everyone like just
entertaining everyone but to me that's
like it's it takes a lot of work for me
to do that and even before sometimes
before as an event I have to psych
myself up to go because I just want to
stay at home and just do my thing be
alone sometimes but I'm like I need to
go to this thing so I have to you know
get myself prepared and then I go and I
do it and I'm actually really happy
after it's done because I went and did
something I didn't want to do and it
ended up actually being like really good
there's a big hill to get over before
you do it though yeah I mean that would
certainly be a big that would be a huge
change for me if I did that it does um
even though standing out the front of a
thousand club nights and meeting a
million people right across a 15 year
Korea
that it didn't feel like socializing I
wasn't properly invested in all of these
people it was just like L small talk
yeah yeah which was good um with drunk
people with very drunk people but I
would have been I I would have liked to
have tuned up the extra version as well
because it does take it does take a a
good chunk of energy for me to go and do
that I've noticed that with these live
shows doing the meet and greet at the
end it's like a high-intensity interval
conversation of 500 600 people in half
an hour or 45 minutes that dude Peterson
going on this tour that he's done which
is basically a permanent a permanent
World Tour and uh he's meeting I think
you need to get a special ticket or
whatever so there's maybe 300 people 400
people a night that have the like big
dick ticket that allows you to get the
the meet and greet but he's doing it
every single night you know like 50
dates 100 dates a year I don't know how
many dude it's for me very very
exhausting I think that he's kind of a
little bit introverted at least as well
so that would be that would be a huge
change what else do I wish that would
change I have a good bit of
self-doubt uh around whether or not I'm
doing the right thing or whether I'm
doing the thing right I think I think
you're doing it right I think certainly
now the the results are showing but
that's the thing I I feel like when when
I see you interview these people I'm
like [__] you were born to do this thank
you and I think it's like you not even
really got started yet well like where
what is what is the goal you want to be
the number one podcast in the world
Rogan's got that title man like the guys
are [__] I I liked what Patrick said
about the the three main uh
characteristics or attributes of a good
or the best uh podcaster yeah one of
them is having that Natural Curiosity
and asking the right questions the other
thing is being able to entertain the the
guest be a good host and the other one
is actually having an audience that
really want to hear your own opinion on
a specific topic yeah I I had a a
conversation about this one of the q&as
at the live show asked about um
basically are you going to do more solo
stuff over the next few years and
I was so
unconfident and so unprepared to think
that I was bigger than I am like who am
I to spout my opinion sat at a table
with Andrew hubman like it's obvious
who's the aide here right it's obviously
him he's the one that's got the
expertise and the the PhD from Stanford
and all the rest of it just let him
shine and I'm really good at letting
other people shine but there definitely
seems to be I don't know there's like
it's it's good to develop your own
opinions around things and to put those
forward and to have faith that what you
have to say might be of use or of
interest to people and more than that to
play with ideas I wonder what happens I
wonder what people think about this I've
got this idea about this thing I wonder
what people think about that but I think
for a good chunk of time as well I was
just so uh concerned about putting
something forward that made me look
stupid I'm going to put this idea
forward and I'm what the the the live
shows no no no no on the show on the
podcast so going to have some idea I've
got a take on whatever the whatever this
thing is like don't comment on things
that you know nothing about but when
you're sat with an expert you're always
you always know nothing in comparison
with the expert even if you know almost
everything in comparison with a normal
person that knows nothing about it right
so because you're I've made a career out
of being the most stupid person in every
conversation do do you feel like there's
a pressure for you to uh improve your
knowledge in all these different areas
cuz you you've had guess
on from every different industry and
market like you feel like [__] I need to
learn more about this and more about
this and more about this so because
being a good host is your ability to
just have like good general knowledge
about [__] everything that's true so
I think I I wanted to do this as a
challenge uh a year ago I wanted to do a
day of recording where I didn't know
anything about the guest I didn't know
who they were and I would just sit down
opposite them and I had to try and hold
a conversation together without like the
audience realizing and me just going
like uh so you know what what do you
think most people get wrong about the
world that you come from like what do
and just like like trying to sort of
work out without actually asking them so
what do you do um I thought that would
be kind of fun to do did you do it I'd
consider I'd still consider doing it I
uh it's a big long list of things that I
want to do but yeah I think one of the
reasons why I stayed clear of putting my
own opinion forward was I didn't want to
feel silly I didn't want to say things
the internet can be a bit of a [__]
ruthless place with playing with ideas
and you know you don't want to you don't
want to look like the idiot in the room
more than you already are but yeah I I
know enough now to be able to hold a
conversation with pretty much anybody
especially if it's about them right if
it's we're talking about Fitness we're
talking about psychology we're talking
about philosophy we're talking about
politics we're talking about whatever
it's I can draw out of pretty much
anyone when it comes to me having my own
takes on stuff I have things that you
know I've got domains of expertise you
want to talk to me about training about
Mental Health about psychology Evolution
like all of these things I've got but if
we start to push out into how are we
going to fix the problems of the Middle
East it's like bro like it's not that's
not my bag and then working out where
the line is between those two uh and not
just spouting more noise into the world
actually adding some signal which is
useful to people that's kind
of that's something that I maybe I
should do more but then another bit of
me thinks well just bring on the guy
that knows and be the person that's able
to get the best answer out of them the
right [__] expert like I don't need
to go on WebMD and try and self diagnose
like whatever ailment I've got it's like
just get the doctor the equivalent of
the doctor on speak to that person but
there's definitely a bit of me that
wants to
do that doesn't just only want to be the
person that plays second string to the
the expert in the room like it'd be
great to be considered an expert in my
own right and yeah it's uh it's
interesting getting past that discomfort
or that uncertainty about whether or not
you have legitimacy because everyone
else has a a million letters after their
name or is a PhD or he's a billionaire
or something and you go the [__] like
why should like I'm just the guy that
asks the questions speaking of
discomfort what was it like the first
time doing the show like the very first
show live show yeah were you [__]
yourself that was nerve-wracking yeah
cuz for me yeah the the thought of that
is pretty Fu scary I think as well it's
Q&A is fine but to to go up there by
yourself and to talk for an hour or more
about something like At first I was
thinking what the hell would I even talk
about what do people even want to
know like I I I guess I would have to
sit down and think about it I'm sure
that there is an audience out there that
want to hear me talk about something
dude I would I i' attend um but yeah the
live shows that I've done I just did one
in Dubai and now I fly to Edmonton for
for 20 hours with James tomorrow morning
at 2: a.m. just going to [__] suck my
soul out of me he's managed to Buck us
one of those things that's like the side
by side seats as well like the with the
dividing door I'm just going to put the
door open not have to speak to the
entire time but standing on stage you
know this is kind of old Trope for
people that listen to Rogan and they're
always on about you work in the material
and the crowd energy and the room and
the vibe and all this sort of stuff but
it's wild to stand on stage and and just
have you know 80 eyes or a thousand eyes
or whatever it was in the Dubai show the
other night like a thousand people there
or whatever like just looking at you and
you can't see the end of the room it's
like it's just endless and then you look
at what Schultz has done he sold out
where the Raptors play in Canada or he
just did this place in in Australia
where it's so far away that they need
screen repeater screens to be able to
see the [__] dude that's just this
little dot down on that and he has the
pressure of having to say something
funny he's got to be funny I mean like
nearly every every 10 20 seconds he has
to say something you got to get a laugh
at least you don't have that pressure
absolutely yeah I mean it's so such a
good Insight that if you're doing a
anything close to public speaking and
you manage to get four zingers in the
space of an hour like you're hilarious
yeah and if you're a comedian that
doesn't get four zingers in a minute
you're [__] so um yeah the the criteria
is very different but it it was it was
very nerve-wracking um I
the most nerve-wracking one that I did
was the very first work in progress show
in Austin so I ran the show four times
in Austin in front of 40 people at this
like tiny kind of rundown Comedy Club
East Austin comedy club and I ran that
four times in front of 40 people but
that's kind of even more scary CU you
can hear like a cough or you can you can
hear like someone's phone vibrate in
their pocket you can hear everything
it's just you in a room I don't even
really need a mic I could probably just
speak and everyone would hear and before
I went on I checked my uh whoop and you
know it's got the stress monitor my
stress is at like 2 you've been cycling
2.8 exactly nice good evening workout
Chris I was just I was just scared um
but to be honest man after a while I
you're so confident in the material um
because it's a set right it's not
scripted but the idea is I know this
idea is interesting and this idea is
interesting and this idea makes people
laugh and this idea makes people cry and
this idea does whatever and after a
while you just have faith that what
you're saying is important it'd be like
me saying to you like here's a word for
word script that you can say that will
make people be interested in what you
say and laugh learn it off by heart go
on stage and say it and I can guarantee
100% that it'll be fine you wouldn't
feel nervous what you're nervous about
is the uncertainty of whether or not
you're going to look silly up on stage
and after you've done sufficient
iterations of anything reps in yeah it's
the same with the show the only
difference is that you don't have the
live audience in front of you having the
live audience in front of you and saying
a thing and then watching them and being
like please love me like God just at
least please don't think that I'm
totally terrible um Jimmy Carr told me a
true Entertainer says if you don't love
me I don't love me and I think that that
kind of I can see how someone who entire
industry is the audience needs to give
me a adoration and that's where I get my
sense of self-esteem from kind of the
same you know looking at the
bodybuilding World which is Ruth because
it's not even a objective metric it's
not that's 380 kilos whichever man that
weighs 93 kilos picks that up wins it's
like subjective and ephemeral and you
know it's like he's got better shape or
conditioning or proportions or whatever
it's very very hard but you're
permanently just Outsourcing your sense
of selfworth to these [__] judges
especially if you're you're competing
and it's yeah it's this the judges you
need to impress and if for whatever
reason they're not impressed they
canally are out this year or like big
thighs are in or whatever yeah it's
crazy yeah but it's it's been very
interesting it's been the veils have
kind of fallen from my eyes a little bit
about seeing super super competent
people up on stage because it the're
infinitely better than I am but you can
just see it's okay it's just one step
after the next watching Jimmy car in
Wembley he did two hours and 20 minutes
of on liners must have been it must have
been 400 jokes in like two and a bit
hours I was like oh my God and we were
with him 30 seconds before he walked out
on stage because I was checking my watch
going like uh you go on stage in 10
minutes you want us to because he might
need to do some pregame ritual or
whatever get his head in the game he's
like no no it's fine stick him up stick
him up and then he's like all right
ready to go boss and like Jimmy's about
to like get the [__] headset on or
whatever and walk out on stage and
they're like should we leave and he's
like yeah yeah yeah krack on I'll see
you out there unbelievable crazy but you
see you know anyone's just accumulated
those skills over time and I think it's
kind of the same with the first time
that you did a YouTube video the first
time you did a podcast the first time
you did whatever there's just this extra
degree of I can see the people watching
and it's yeah first time I did a podcast
I was like what am I doing who was your
first one is Will Will Ahmed the founder
went straight into the deep end with a
CEO founder of a billion a billion
company crazy but yeah it's like the
moment you start doing more and more of
them it just becomes normal I can
imagine like especially for you doing
three a week you're what you're in the
700s now this will be 720 something like
that yeah it must be so normal yeah it
is and that's something that's quite
bizarre um to do something very alien I
mean think about this Pawn Stars I would
love to ask our friend Lauren whether or
not it's like whether there's still
Intimacy in that cuz what you're looking
at a conversation like this usually very
messy very
unstructured someone will get up and go
and do a thing people are on their phone
you know there's like all structural
side to things plus then there's cameras
plus then there's a team of people plus
then there's you know it's going out to
an audience and there's going to be
scrutiny and there's going to be
criticism there's going to be whatever
so it's like a something that you're
familiar with in an alien environment
and I wonder whether Pawn Stars feel the
same something that you can be quite
familiar with but in a even more alien
environment like it's it's this I think
I was being Sterling his ex porn star
and he was saying that even there with
some actresses there's just an instant
chemistry that you can't really explain
but it's just like a thing and it just
makes things automatically very spicy
and flow naturally whereas sometimes
it's just like robotic there's nothing
there and it's just very forced but yet
you have to try and force that chemistry
yeah like tell when you watch porn if
it's like if they're having a good time
or not how much porn do you watch oh
what's porn yeah s um but yeah it's
weird to think like can people
reintegrate this is one thing so I've
been doing therapy in uh Austin this
lady's great this woman that I've been
working with why why why does you need
therapy I think that everyone does I
genuinely think that everybody would
benefit from just I would love to have
uh I don't know if it would be therapy
or just to speak to an expert on
relationship mhm because I feel like
that is something every day every year
I'm still learning more about
relationships and how do they work are
you with the right person like what I'm
sure there's a lot of things wrong with
me I don't think I'm an easy person to
date especially with my my job the way I
look social media it's whoever I'm in a
relationship with they have to be they
got to deal with that yeah they got to
deal with the fact that I'll get
attention and you know probably if I'm
with a really hot girl which I have been
in the past like days obviously have
attention as well but I'm cool with that
it's um it's a tricky one and I think
like I I've always been pretty
horrendous at
communicating that's just who I am like
I would just I don't know I keep I keep
a lot of my feelings to myself and just
assume that they know what's going on or
that everything's all right but in
reality you need to have a pretty hard
conversation Neil Strauss the guy that
wrote the game who is now kind of this
super aligned awakened Family Man uh
this [__] awesome quote from him that
said unspoken expectations are
premeditated
resentments Jesus Christ unspoken
expectations are premeditated
resentments and you know when you're
talking about that I I will maybe keep
my feelings to myself I won't really
mention something that's either bugging
me or that I wish that I would bring up
but you get the sense that the other
person should know or might know or
could know or whatever and after a while
you almost end up building a
conversation with yourself about the
thing that you never said to the person
who didn't know it um so yeah I mean
Bill Perkins that wrote die with zero
one of the most dialed systems guys that
I know Ali abdal came out to out [__]
wake surfing with us Ali had a bad day
bet he was good at thate Alex OK Conor
Cosmic skeptic came out and stood up
first first try Yousef my friend went
out EO foiling yesterday over there
stood up within the first session Ali
abdal not like I mean so just insanely
smart and I think he's got he's got like
I can't remember what he's good at he's
good at like some physical sport but
like it wasn't [__] wake surfing
anyway he asked Bill Perkins what's the
number one coach that you've got out of
everything the business coaching all the
rest of it he's like relationship coach
first thing he said relationship coach
most important they check in I think
both Partners work separately and then
they maybe do couples I think after to
begin with in the honeymoon period is
fine you don't need any help like it
just it runs itself but the longer the
relationship goes on for like after a
year after 2 years that's when you have
to work at it that's what I've learned
you know after a 2year relationship
there there things you got to work on um
and there's a lot still which I need to
learn I've had a lot of relationships
that have been six months put it that
way honeymoon period and and over this
episode is brought to you by factor I
get asked all the time about how to
build and maintain muscle and the most
important thing the first thing you need
to do is ensure you are getting one
grand per kilo of body weight in protein
every single day but as you know if
youve ever tried to cook anything ever
consistently you'll stick to your Macros
finding whole food healthy meals you can
have conveniently every single day is
difficult this is where Factor comes in
they're fresh never frozen meals are
designed by registered dietitians and
arrive ready to heat and eat in minutes
it requires zero prep so if you are
someone that says I'd love to hit my
protein numbers but I never have time to
cook prep takes so long and I hate doing
it this is the solution for you so if
you want to make an improvement to your
diet this August you can get factor and
start eating better without the hassle
head to the link in the description
below or go to factor meals.com
mw50 and use the code mw50 for 50% off
your first order a checkout that's
factor meals.com
mw50 and mw50 a checkout someone who has
seen [__] insane growth is Sam suck
oh God yeah what do you think about Sam
suck
I'm I am this is I'm so fascinated how
certain people just pop off on social
media like I'm trying to understand the
what has the formula been like I didn't
I didn't know of him before until it's
basically kind of you see the memes
first you're like why is there a meme
about this guy and then you go onto the
Instagram you go on to the YouTube and
you just see like the the following and
the consistently high views and like oh
what's he what's he doing then and you
watch it and it's just like
pretty normal there's no fancy edits or
anything cinematic it's just I think the
reason why it's worked so well is
because he's just gotten almost in the
opposite direction in in in instead of
trying too hard with like the showing
off and the the music the edits he's
just like this is just is edits it's
just
it's like after that first thing it's
just as far as I know it's just the
camera on a tripod and he's just doing
his thing and sharing his thoughts which
is very simple
but it can't after watching it it makes
sense why it works he has some in a lot
of insightful things to say I think uh I
heard this term the other day growth
hacking
authenticity um and I think that
everybody now is
so skeptical of someone that's
contriving uh a a version of themselves
if you see someone that looks like
they're trying too hard or they're
putting on a a particular it's just
there's discomfort and ick and oh I
don't like that and I
think Sam's lack of fancy car or fancy
edit or fancy thumbnails or like any of
that is just a signal of reliability I
think that's what people I think it's
very relatable if you think about how
many men are in a similar situation to
him I remember when I when I started the
YouTube channel like everything was
really basic I was in you know not a
very it was a terrorist house in
Newcastle I was doing my meal prep video
in a pretty shabby kitchen my pots and
pans were all completely [__] up like
there was no lubrication on it it was
just sticking to everything and I was
just doing my meal prep shopping at
little or Aldi and just taking it to
work with me and people love that cuz so
many people could relate to it and I
remember the moment I kind of moved
moved away from that staying in more
fancier places when I upgraded to my
apartment in London and I left London
and came to Dubai it was my audience was
divided there was half of them who were
like really inspired and they were like
wow like look what he's done I want to
do this as well and then there's the
other half who were just like I I can't
really relate to you anymore like I
can't relate to your
life well I mean make make no mistake
man if I was to guess the revenue that
Sam is making per month forget his
hostile uh sponsorship and forget the
other stuff just from
AdSense I reckon it's at least a quarter
of a m yeah he's banging out a video
nearly every day daily videos of half a
mil yeah probably quter of a m a month
there is always Trends in the industry
like something comes along from nowhere
and is very
popular but there's very few things that
remain that popular over a long period
of time like will it get to a point
where his style of videos are not going
to do it for people like it gets to a
point where it's oh it's boring now like
let me find something what's the next
hot trending thing yeah well there's
definitely for every Trend there is a
counterculture Trend so I said this
before if you want to predict the future
look at a trend that exists now for
which there hasn't yet been the exact
opposite so for every um let's say like
Mike thirst well-edited Fitness Vlog
with like cool [__] cinematic
lighting and a guy with a Gimbal and
stuff there's a Sam suck which is kind
of the same thing but delivered in in a
very different sort of a way um summer
2020 everyone's locked down no one can
go out summer 2021 Megan the stallion
just hot girl summer dress yourself up
go out you know like have casual sex
like be dled and Glam summer 2022 is
feral girl summer which is be a sloth
don't shave don't wash you don't need to
be bothered even leaving the house just
eat beans in your p jamas so like you
have culture or Trend and then Counter
Culture or counter Trend and I think
that Sam largely is not necessarily
probably worst example to use you I
don't know who he's quite the antithesis
of but he's definitely counter to much
of the fitness industry that is
contrived that's like um you know kind
of like the equivalent of the pop Idol
boy band that was like pieced together
like you're the cool one and you're the
whatever one it doesn't feel like that
it's just some bloke going about his day
but and I I said this on an episode with
Zach and people got mad about it I still
think it's the truth if Sam wasn't Elite
level jacked people wouldn't follow him
I think that what works about Sam if Sam
was some skinny skinny fat guy that
wasn't in good condition wasn't lifting
heavy and didn't have really great
insight about Fitness he's just some
bloke going to the gym that's a lot of
people trying that's all that's
everyone's YouTube that's every person's
YouTube channel I think that Sam is a
likable relatable guy who happens to be
[__] massive and it's like oh like
he's me but better yeah he's so much of
what we have is relatable and is the
same and on top of that he's you know
bodybuilder huge was like I look at [__]
as well like seum has this huge huge
like he is the biggest name in
bodybuilding now and I try and think
okay so why why is that the case
obviously he he looks amazing but he's
such a nice humble guy as well that I
can't imagine why anyone would ever have
a problem with him so you combine that
super jacked amazing physique with just
being a nice humble guy and it does
without a doubt get harder to remain
humble when you have that many people
who are idolizing you and you have like
over 21 million people following you to
not let that get to your head is well
there's two two ways that it can get to
your head the first one being your ego
is being inflated by everyone thinking
that you're great the second one is you
becoming defensive and bitter about all
of the people criticizing you yeah so
you it works in two different ways I'm
going to become more harsh and and more
uh quick to attack because people have
done it to me in the past and all of
these people are telling me that I'm
great and I've got five championships
how the [__] am I not like the best and
everyone should listen to me like hard
it's hard to especially if you're
combining it with like if you're taking
some steroids as well like that can also
mess up with your mentality in the way
that you're thinking yeah yeah I
wonder you know I was watching uh a
couple of videos from the trend twins as
well and uh they're like I find them
like a pretty interesting interesting
pair like they're an interesting pair of
dudes but uh Sam is just a [__]
Phenom at the moment uh what's his face
cam Haynes brought him up to Rogan
yesterday on uh on his show have you
heard of this Sam suck kid it's like
there you go Derek from more plates more
dates did it as well in a little way I
think he you know he purposefully didn't
make his uh yeah like he he could have
definitely leveled up with the
production yep but like no no people
just wanted that like
relatability like high level
Insight sprinkling of autism like that's
what they wanted from sometimes I try
not to get too heavily influenced you
know I've had Iman gadzi on the show the
production quality on his videos is
absolutely like insane like best of the
best and then I'm thinking [__] maybe I
need to get to that that level of
production but I I don't I don't need to
I just just focus on what it is that
you're going to say thing cuz if you go
too hard with the production it it gets
a bit distracting and maybe again it
becomes unrelatable how do you think
about enoughness you know the the stress
and and responsibility and paranoia that
comes along for the ride with wanting
more and success and money can kind of
sap the fun out of it do you think about
enoughness I think
um it's harder to fall asleep quicker
that's for sure because when I go to bed
I'm just thinking about all the things
that I need to do should be doing and
haven't done so that's taking hit CU I
remember in my 20s I never had a I I
remember just I just fall asleep
straight away now it's a lot harder
um and yeah I I think especially right
now I'm in a position where if I really
want to can go full steam ahead and
really take things to the next level
like everything is in my favor I have
the team I have you know I'm living here
in duby I'm at a point where I I have a
following have some respect so let's go
fully into this but then that's going to
come at a price and I know if if that's
something which I want to do you know if
you want all the numbers to be
increasing the subscribers increasing
the views the money you know I'm going
to have to say goodbye to a couple cple
of things and it's it's going to be a
sacrifice with relationships it's going
to be a sacrifice to the things which I
like to do sometimes that's like to just
wake up and do nothing and do my own
thing just go for a walk just chill take
life easy like I I love nothing more
than doing that sometimes which I had a
kind of experience of doing that over
the summer where I wasn't working as
much less productive really just
enjoying life and what I've achieved
fruits of my labor but then after a
couple of days or weeks of doing that
you just feel like [__] I'm kind of I'm
wasting my potential here and things are
starting to go in the reverse Direction
and I think that was quite a sort of
scary experience for me I had a big
break from doing the podcast I think I
got up to
um was it was it 20 episodes you know I
don't think I'd got myself into that 1%
I was just shy and I was like
[__] the GU [__] guy I'm that guy
that gave up yeah and I notic when I
when I stopped doing the podcast um CU I
didn't have my team with me I was in
like traveling about a bit I I think I
just wasn't for whatever reason I'd lost
the motivation a little bit but I just
felt um like I was doing a disservice to
my audience everyone was asking me is
like when's the next episode when's the
next episode I was just
like I don't know and I just felt like
what a [__] waste I am like I have
this potential and opportunity to create
these amazing conversations with amazing
people but I'd rather just go to a beach
club or go on a date with this girl or
just [__] about well there's a pressure
that comes with that and yeah I think
about enoughness a good bit I want to
I've got another episode with hosi
coming up uh probably within the next
few months I want to try and really dig
into it because I know that he's 99th
percentile of hardworking guy it's very
inspiring to be around but I wonder
how scalable and replicable that is with
people who don't have his very
particular Quirk of mindset I I listen
to him and I'm like [__] I would like a
little bit more of his yes mindset I I
want more of that I like to work I want
to do more work I want to do less of the
the fun things that people want to do
but one thing you do realize like saying
I want to do less of the fun things like
why are you doing more of the work
presumably because the work is fun so
like the more direct root to it is is
just doing the fun thing I think if you
if you can find a way that your your job
is fun then that's that helps a lot like
me and I you as well having the
opportunity to speak to some amazing
people it's pretty it's a rewarding job
and having a very positive impact on the
world like that's it feels pretty damn
good and it doesn't doesn't really feel
like work it's a pleasure to be able to
do this for a living I think it's
absolutely crazy like even this morning
training with Kai green like what I get
to train with some of the best
bodybuilders on the planet that's a
[__] dream yeah and I've been able
I've got myself into a position where I
can do that there's there's definitely a
and again this I think this is for
everybody
you have opportunities that are in front
of you and if you're even remotely
competent at what you do you will always
have more opportunities than time to do
them in is it your role in life to take
every single opportunity that comes your
way what is life outside of those
opportunities like how much are you
grinding this great quote from Morgan
housel that says the best measure of
wealth is what you have minus what you
want and by this measure some
billionaires are broke and it's kind of
the same as what do you want from a an
achievement perspective like you know
what's good with me I feel like a lot of
the things I wanted to do I did in my
20s like I really did there's a list of
things I really did a lot of things I
wanted to do and I think once you've
done them you realize majority of the
time it's not actually as good as you
thought it would be you do it and you're
like uh yeah it was good but it was a
little bit of a it was a bit of a
letdown like I thought it was going to
be better and once you've kind of
checked off more things on the list you
know you just get like more and more
motivated to actually just do do some
work and be of
use yeah yeah there's definitely like a
a bit of [__] that goes on when
you're a kid and you you're happy to
just bounce around and and have fun but
then as you grow up you realize okay
well my time's actually [__] limited
yeah like so what am I here to do am I
here to work and not leave anything on
the table or am I here to find time to
this is still dude it must be the most
common theme of questions that I've
probably asked anybody this year and
it's maybe
um telling given like how this year has
gone how can you balance being enough
whilst wanting to be
more like feeling comfortable and
content and your mind is where your feet
are in the moment and being able to take
pleasure in the things that you do and
the successes that you have whilst also
knowing that you don't want to leave
anything on the table and you want to
try and maximize your time here your
brief period of 80 years on this planet
and it's still you know Sam Harris had
this really beautiful idea about the
balance of being and becoming it was
really lovely but tactically I have to
say I'm I'm struggling to still really
really get that
balance nailed because so much of what
you do when you want to become better I
want to become bigger I want to become
leaner I want to become richer I want to
move to a better house I want to move to
a better neighborhood I want to be
smarter I want to be more articulate
what all of those things as soon as you
posit that ideal you then start to
compare yourself to that ideal and you
find yourself lacking and in that lack
is dissatisfaction that rips you out of
the present moment but the only reason
that you're doing that is presumably so
that when you get there you're like ah
now I can be in the present moment but
each goal that you hit just pushes
another goal it's like oh well like yeah
I mean I've done the 21st episode so
like now it's it's got to be 50 right
like 50 is the next goal or 100 an next
goal or it's a million blah blah blah
blah blah like there's always just
another thing I think it's really
important to celebrate the winds like to
go out and like if you do hit a
particular Milestone just go out and
celebrate it and then yeah come back and
then set a new goal I think it's the
most difficult thing I've had now
particularly when I go through phases
where I'm super motivated and I want to
grow it's like the Friendship aspect and
the relationship aspect takes a hit like
if you're trying to go full steam ahead
with your business and your all these
opportunities you have in front of you
I've noticed when I've been in a
relationship any spare time that I have
I have to devote that to my partner
which then means I have to [__] my
friends off yeah whereas if let's say
for example I was single then that gives
me an opportunity to spend more time
with my friends like to try and juggle
everything is really difficult I think
Ryan holiday's got uh scene business
family pick two you can be a part of the
scene you can be successful in business
can be great part of your family but
it's really really really rough to do
all three uh who I say that seems to
have got it all I don't know much about
Joe's uh family life although it seems
he seems to have got that pretty dialed
Jo yeah yeah
um he he seems to have certainly got two
of them two of them sorted imagine us
like we're in a situ situation now we
don't even have kids and we're already
[__] complaining mental mental mental
mental mental but yeah I um I know what
you mean Oliver burkman has this other
idea about uh choose in advance what
you're going to suck at which is pretty
cool so for a period of time you're
going to work on your business and
you're going to grow your net worth or
you're going to try and double the
revenue of your business or you're going
to try and get a raise or get a
promotion or do whatever that period of
life just as important as what are you
going to do is what you prepared to
sacrifice for it because you know if you
need to stay late in the office three
nights a week for the next six months so
that your boss sees the work that you're
doing or so that you get more sales in
or so that you what do whatever it is
that you need to do your trading's
probably going to take a hit yeah and
when you start to see your condition or
your Fitness depreciate over time if
you're a typ a go-getter you can feel
uncomfortable and say oh well I that
shouldn't be happening and then you take
your eye off the ball of the thing that
was supposed to be your thing for the
next six months and then go I'll I'll
only stay late in the office one night a
week and I'll get I'll fit training I'll
slot training in two more nights you go
well that wasn't the plan the plan was
put everything into this one thing level
myself up and then play catch up with
everything else to bring myself back up
to Baseline um so yeah choose in advance
what you want to suck at uh is like a
really really good tactic because it
helps you when other things start to
slip yeah it stops IT feeling like uh an
error or or um a curse of some kind and
actually is like oh this is part of the
plan this this this was actually part of
the plan part of the plan was I wouldn't
get to see my friends as much or my
sleep would suffer or my fitness would
suffer or my business would suffer
because we've just had a kid or whatever
like I think that's important and that
thing that sucks at the moment it's not
going to suck later on precisely like
you can easily switch out suck yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I think like especially
right now for the next couple of years
next five years I want to go all in on
just okay let's try and
build a solid business businesses
whatever it might be
make myself extremely financially
comfortable so that later on you know
when I get to my late 30s 40s when it's
time to you know really raise a family
I'm in a very comfortable situation
where I can do that and then devote more
of my time to raising my kids and being
there for my
partner that's that's the plan that I I
think I've got as well that one of my
friends David Perell told me most of my
20s was spent making myself into the dad
that my future kids deserve and I really
like that idea that you're putting a lot
of work in now which is gratifying in
the moment it would be like way way too
full of myself to be like and all of
this is for the sacrifice for my future
kids like no it's not like I I take
loads of pleasure from the things that I
do Matt Matt do Fitness does a great job
of raising his kids does he he's a very
good role model for being a father like
he's Chad to Dad pipeline yeah he's just
he's he he's in a position where he
doesn't have to go to work he's even
built like a home gym at home so he can
just spend more time with his family and
like you just you can see how well he's
raised his two boys like whenever you're
around them they're just like the
happiest most positive like even
comfortable in front of the camera
they're already like really skilled at
like loads of random different things
because Matt has been there all the time
to wow teach them educate them and push
them but you've got to have that it's
interesting what you say I think I
always about the finance thing I think I
always kind of Steed clear of commenting
on finances largely because I came from
such a [__] workingclass background
that money was just never a
consideration and it it it wasn't really
that much of a discussion always um so I
kind of stayed clear of talking about it
but you know Tate mentioned it too that
until you're financially liberated
you're kind of at the mercy of a lot of
things and financially liberated doesn't
mean like compound in Romania it just
means more money than you need to be
able to live and not having to
compensate by working an insane number
of hours that ruins the rest of your
life outside of it so much more freedom
yeah it is I
mean it's funny now as you as obviously
the podcast has grown you have more
staff to take care of like you've got
salaries to pay for now you've got
Studios to pay for yeah it's not that
you need to earn more money so you can
live a better life it's no I need to
also earn more money so I can take the
quality of my production to the next
level and Ure that I can keep giving you
guys the best so I can fly to the other
side of the planet to go and speak to
this guy yeah yeah it's it's an
interesting one man I
um I don't know it's it's like a it's
been very a very interesting year like
quite a disquieting year in some ways
like so satisfying but also just rapid
changes in status this is one of the
things about like kid like Sam
who even more than either of us in terms
of the rapidity of his change of status
people say that they want you know Fame
and and Accolade and and wealth but just
how it thrown at you is [__]
terrifying yeah I had this idea um that
I learned from Jimmy Carr trajectory is
way more important than position if
you're number two in the world but last
year you were number one that is way
worse than sitting at number 150 but
being on a huge upward slope from number
300 12 months ago there's a few reasons
for this recency bias if your value is
increasing now that means that you have
to be popular at the moment by looking
at recent trajectory you're selecting
for only the people who are trendy right
now which really is all that we can can
remember we can also romanticize where
someone will be in future if they're
currently hot [__] how high might they
go who knows maybe to the top even maybe
even beyond the top humans struggle to
realize that everything is temporary
including growth and decline instead
it's easy to label people as Heroes and
losers based on what we know of them
right now so we don't have to predict a
messy future there's an old saying that
there's three types of people on the
ladder one at the bottom one at the
middle and one at the top which one is
the best to be the one that's still
climbing this doesn't just work for
status but possessions achieve ments
wealth sex and everything else it's not
just how we see other people it's also
how we see ourselves we know when we're
moving up or down when life is getting
better or worse Andrew Tate said having
things isn't fun getting things is fun
another way to look at this is any
accomplishment is just a new higher bar
for you to get over in future I see this
in my own work let's say that we do a
new episode that hits a million players
in a day amazing that's very exciting in
a new record wow also that means that
every video in future is now going to
feel unimpressive unless it 1.1 million
views higher in 24 hours in this way
rapid increases in status are more a
curse than a blessing so here's a theory
which I co-signed with Dan Bilzerian a
few weekends ago so you know it's legit
even though we might want our goals and
accomplishments to arrive immediately
maybe a Str a smarter strategy is to
stretch out the achievements of our
dreams we shouldn't wish for overnight
success as we would then need to be able
to beat it pretty soon lest we feel like
we're declining instead slow consistent
progress is a more reliable way to
maintain satisfaction purposefully
aiming for slow success strategy may
actually ensure you always feel like
you're going in the right direction 100%
it's almost like when you if you were to
win the lottery like if you were to be
given 100 Mil versus actually working
your ass off over time your salary or
however much money you're earning
gradually increases and then you get to
that point where okay now I've got 100
Mil which one is more satisfying it's a
curse that would I think you would look
back on it
as almost certainly the best and worst
day of your life at the same time you
got gifted a unbelievable amount of
money or an unbelievable amount of
status or whatever how are you ever
going to have a better day than that day
I always thought that oh God it'd be so
cool if I won the lottery but it would
it would literally [__] me up in the
worst way yeah I would hate that yeah
it's weird man it's weird the way that
we play with status and um what's the
energy that you're trying to prioritize
in your life at the moment like what is
it what sort of people do you want
around you what sort of vibe are you
trying to prioritize I think um people
who are going to help inspire me I think
that's
what I struggle with sometimes on a
day-to-day B basis with being motivated
especially when you when you've got to
the point where you've got everything
you really need like look I'm mean this
I have a ice car I have a nice apartment
I've got great friends like I me what
more do I really need in my life
when I spend more time with people who
are ahead of me financially
business-wise whatever it might be even
just being around
them gives me a I don't know it I guess
I'm kind of a little bit competitive as
well like it makes me want to be oh no I
want to get to that level yeah so it
makes me think okay there's there's
levels to achieve with this um I'm
certainly past the days where I was
interested in like the the partying and
doing that kind of thing I think when we
last spoke it was already getting to
that point but even now I I compare what
what my desires were at the start of
this year compared to what my desires
are now and they've definitely changed
for the better what do you think caused
that to
happen um I think just coming to the
realization of what is like really
important um knowing that a lot of
things which I've wanted to do I've done
and I think I i' put myself in a few
situations this summer where I had been
at like parties obviously I went to ATA
a couple times doing the usual
debauchery and then um just thinking
[__] I don't this is I don't like doing
this anymore I really don't like I don't
get as much enjoyment from it but I hate
the way it makes me feel I think with
what I'm doing now you know especially
with what we do doing the podcast being
on YouTube I have to be on it like all
the time and I actually really enjoy
this elevated state which I'm at like
there is no alcohol there's nothing
which is slowing me down so if you do go
out and you drink or you do anything
negative for your for your health or
your
mindset just waking up and feeling
groggy and [__] is like it's horrible I
want to wake up every day feeling as
good as I could possibly feel and you
know when you know when you have a
really good sleep and you wake up and
you're like oh my God that was a good
sleep you feel like you've taken a
freaking Limitless pill I want that
every day
yeah that's
um I I know Iman Gad is a big fan of
Monk mode but it's one of the most
addicting parts of Monk mode that
nothing ever knocks you off that routine
yeah that you're permanently in this
like hermetically sealed box right
nothing is coming in nothing is nudging
it nothing is breaking it just perfect
routine at all times and all you're
optimized for is that and it can be very
very addicting uh it's even one thing
which I I love to do I used to travel
loads but now I'm actually I don't want
to travel because I know it's going to
knock me off this very good routine
which I have going on that's that's
something that's cool that I kind of
wish I could gift more people if I could
gift
them a Pursuit that they're they're
needing maximum sort of cognitive
horsepower and they can do it
sufficiently frequently that they notice
the the fluctuations between themselves
the last couple of days my sleep's just
been so wrecked since I've been here I
don't know how you do it with the amount
of traveling you do yeah it's it's not
easy most of the travel when it's with
inside the US it's fine but the one that
we did here was was pretty brutal um and
last night we were at dinner and I was
trying to think of this word I was
trying to think of this word and it
wasn't there I just know that it's
because I'm underslept yeah and but
being able to play with that tolerance I
guess like an athlete right you know the
speed that you're usually able to run at
or cut at or you know jump or or lift or
whatever and you go this isn't there
today why is that not there and then you
start to investigate a little bit but
it's so cool and know knowing
the knowing the the contributing factors
to that and then having a Pursuit that
allows to act as a barometer for it is
brilliant because you go okay well this
is my reinforcement mechanism for me
focusing on making myself better because
I can feel when I make myself better and
I can feel when I make myself worse it's
way easier to make myself even a tiny
bit worse than it is to make myself even
less of a bit better so yeah I think um
focusing on those
focusing on like things that are going
to help you be better long term is what
locks you off your good routine apart
from travel sleep is the main one it's
the biggest determinant of how I perform
on the podcast yeah um if I haven't
slept well if I haven't trained
consistently have you ever needed to
cancel because you're that never never
never never never even at my worst I'm
still I'm still pretty good so I'm fine
to I'm fine to take over and hold it
together but I'll know because I'll know
what I could have said yeah that that
feeling of regret after you like a
little bit it's it's usually during I
don't have that much regret once I've
once we finished cuz I'm like oh look
like I can't go back and redo it but
while it's happening I find myself
chastising myself about Lex has spoken
about this you'll say a word imprecisely
or you'll say a sentence that could have
been nicer could have been more lean and
as you're saying it you'll think that
was [__] [__] like I must must do
better but yeah sleep is a big one sugar
is a huge one for me if I've had um I
don't know why I would do this I
wouldn't do this but if I went and had a
a massive Armond quason and a hot
chocolate or something before I went to
go and record all like like inflamed and
sluggish and stuff awful but what I
found I operate really well on is uh
meat and fat and a little bit of fruit
on the morning and in my my I can pretty
much eat as much of that as I want and I
don't ever feel a crash off the other
side of it so most mornings it's like a
the fasted could be a bit risky it is
because you risk falling off a cliff and
you don't have any energy so I found for
me ton of scram like four scrambled eggs
some bacon uh you know like maybe some
sourdough toast usually not uh and then
nice bowl of fruit or something mixed
berries or something like that and that
if I have that at 9:00 a.m. that can
carry me through till 300 p.m. easily
just off the back of that and then a
little bit of caffeine and and and some
other stuff will will take me over but
yeah man sleep sugar both of those are
absolutely ruin your ruin the way that
your mind food [__] me up what's going
on next what can people expect from you
over the next couple of oh you've got
new t-shirts which you've got on oh yeah
you ear one I don't know no I no cuz you
the only ones that you were able to give
me infested with your musk yeah um new
products coming out with the the
clothing side of things it's an
interesting Journey with that obviously
you will be aware like releasing a
physical product um I'm going to keep
trying to scale that I've got a course
coming out mid
December Fitness it's going to be more
so with social media how to build uh
predominantly a YouTube platform but how
to monetize it so how to get to the
point where within six months you can
make £1,000 a month of it wow that is
the that's the
blueprint um and yeah just keep cracking
on with the podcast I feel as though
it's doing well um I'm only doing one a
week and I feel like hey imagine what
you could achieve if you did two a week
yeah like it just grow twice as fast
yeah well I mean and then I have my my
main Channel which is well you're trying
to kind of water that as well yes it's
I'm trying to figure out what is the
optimal way to do everything so that
everything kind of grows flourishes yeah
I think you should do a newsletter I
think I told you this last time yeah but
I think you know what you have felt as
an enjoyment from doing the podcast and
having these conversations doing the
same thing for yeah writing even if
you're not a writer which I'm wasn't
before I started and now I'm
200 1,000 word blog posts in like
200,000 words over whatever would you
write yourself yeah yeah yeah yeah every
single week and I I it's one of the most
fun things that I do over a weekend I'll
think what what the [__] did I learn
this week there's 500 Words and then
who's coming up and then give me some
I'm always looking out for facts I'm
always looking at it's same reason why
doing a gratitude Journal is good
because you know that at the end of the
day you need to find something to be
[__] grateful about so during the day
you're always scouring for things to do
it um but I highly highly recommend and
use letter apart from the fact that it's
amazing as a a marketing tool um it's
genuinely enjoyable and I really really
think that it it brings value to people
in a way that even YouTube and
podcasting can't it's so lean and it it
really it acts almost like a public
journal for you and obviously you get to
choose the level of uh openness of
vulnerability transparency about your
own life but yeah uh I'd subscribe the
[__] out of that so dude I'm excited I'm
excited to see what we get up to over
the next year when's the book coming out
oh god um should be start of 2025 um if
everything goes well but so another year
in a bit another year and a bit so six
months to write six months to publish is
interesting the way that it works but
it's the publishing thing is is just
such a big slow Behemoth to spin up um
but yeah should hopefully be done by
then that being said I haven't really
thought Beyond this tour I get myself
back to Austin on the 11th of December
and that's like get up to that point and
then limp limp to the UK for Christmas
and then just sleep at Mom and Dad's for
a I'm looking forward to that there'll
be a at least a week period where I kind
of have just trying to forget about
everything and just being the present
especially with family yeah yeah dude I
appreciate you thank you for coming on
again thank you bro pleasure as always
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a ful length 2hour podcast
episode with Mr Olympia classic physique
Chris Bumstead go on press it